oh here you go walking just one more
minute a day think about this for a
second can have a positive impact on
your mental health research shows you do
not have to run a marathon that's good
or take a tough fitness class to see
results that's simply just moving around
your house can help you fight loneliness
and depression and it can also promote
happiness this is all explained in a
brand new book it's called the joy of
movement how exercise helps us find
happiness hope connection and courage
it's written by psychologist Kelly
McGonigal and she joins us at the table
hey Kelly McGonigal because you say that
this book is a love letter to movement
of all forms why because you love humans
and I thought I love humans too and so
after you were doing all the research
you would say people are incredible I
just love them but this is what struck
me about you you said that exercise can
make you a better version of yourself
what do you mean by that yes so this
really works in two ways one we know
that when you're active when you get
your heart rate up when you use your
muscles
it changes your brain chemistry in a way
that makes you more hopeful and
optimistic and better able to connect
with others for me I experience it as
making me braver and better able to
handle sorry oh ho yeah well you know
like so my natural temperament is super
anxious and but when I work out I find
that I can actually handle challenges
better I just feel like I can take on
the world so this actually combats
depression and loneliness and loneliness
and anxiety and can help people recover
from from grief and trauma I mean the
research is really clear and you know
you mentioned I said that I love people
I heard so many stories that were really
inspiring about people who were able to
move forward because they found a form
of movement that made them feel
differently about themselves and what
they were capable of when you talk about
movement what do you mean yeah anything
using your body to engage with life so
it could be exercise like running or
walking it could be dancing and you're
dancing in your living room with your
kids could be gardening it could be
powerlifting and sensing your own
strength but you know movement is really
about using our bodies in order to
connect with others to do things that
matter I think and many of us experience
that in exercise but talking about
running a marathon not necessary it can
be I mean it doesn't have it does not
have to be I mean you can get a runner's
high from wall
okay with your dog and you can also do
any form of movement that has meaning or
purpose to you for some people it'll be
running a marathon you you write that
movement releases and I love this phrase
a hope molecule yeah I like that what is
amazing finding that you really move
your necklace it's hitting your mic yeah
so speaking a lot of noise yeah just
turn it around okay
people to hear what you're saying yeah
so when you exercise your muscles
actually secrete chemicals into your
bloodstream that work like an
antidepressant so every time you
exercise any form at all and you use
your muscles you're giving yourself an
intravenous dose of hope you said
physical accomplished accomplished meant
scan change how you think about yourself
yeah you said all of us have a tough
mudder in us a high terror low horror
thing not me and everybody has that holy
bleep moment where they think I can't do
it and then I do yeah and so you know
for some people it is like a Tough
Mudder where you're jumping off some
high plank into a pit of water
for some people like me it's learning
how to do a headstand and to go upside
down and face that for your well that
don't like exercise because I really do
hate it I but I don't want to be a fat
emic fat fat and I want to be healthy
but I just really don't like it so for
people who don't like it what do you say
to those people I would say um if you
value exercise you want the benefits of
exercise pair it with something that you
already love so you and I were talking
about music and the right way list can
make almost anything so enjoyable and
pair it with people you care about do it
in a place that inspires you like spend
time exercising outdoors I'm do it with
a purpose so one of the groups are write
about in the book good gym they actually
meet up as a community in their
neighborhood they run a couple miles to
do a community service project and then
they run back and have dinner I mean
there really is a way to integrate
movement into your life and not just
said movement is natural even newborns
you said 48 hours out of the womb womb
they can detect a B yeah I'm you do see
kids just joyfully dance yes who can't
even walk whoo we're just moving to him
yeah they call that groove it's the
instinct to move to music and again it's
hardwired in us and there are a lot of
joys of movement that are like oh you're
not getting the runner's high let me get
through it
but your enthusiasm is infectious and I
like that thank you very much Kelly
Macdonald for joining us again the joy
movement is on sale now
you like to buy your books
you